coming up on Star Talk Cosmic queries
I've got Chuck nice with me and we have
as our guest theoretical physicist
Delilah Gates and she's an expert on
everything space-time geometry we're
going to learn what that is we're going
to find out if in a spherical Universe
where whether we can see the back of the
head of our own Milky Way uh does the
rest of the universe abide by Newton's
laws or Einstein's laws is the universe
curved and
is there a center of the universe all of
this lives within the understandings of
the universe that comes to us by
studying the space-time Continuum of it
next on Star Talk
[Music]
is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition I
got Chuck nice with me to help me out
here Chuck how you doing man hey Neil
what's happening
all right all right this is a cosmic
queries on gravity and space-time
geometry oh my God you know why aren't
we being a you know you know we we
really should be as Elementary as
possible you know just just the
basically get the basics we need to get
these Basics out of the way and I think
this is a great time to do it you know
yeah yeah so
whatever I know about this it's not
enough to do a whole show on it and so
we got to get we have to we we've we
found one of the world's experts on this
subject and she's with us today Delilah
Gates Delilah welcome to Star Talk hi
thanks for having me hey yeah yeah and
and from your resume here you are
freshly minted PhD like 18 months ago or
something right
oh wow you know what I'm brand new I
thought that was it you got that new
doctor smell
well as long as it's a pleasant one I'll
take it there you go absolutely
absolutely you got your your PhD in
physics from Harvard a couple of years
ago and now you're at the Princeton
gravity initiative so right what is that
what does that even mean so
yeah the gravity initiative is a center
here at Princeton
um and most of the people involved with
it are post-docs and Affiliated
professors and a few grad students and
we are a bunch of people who ask
questions about compact objects by which
I mean objects that have the strongest
gravity that we have in our universe
that's uh black holes and neutron stars
and also people who study uh questions
of math related to general relativity
and gravity as well so because is that
because what Einstein realized was that
their entire branches of mathematics
that you need that the physicists might
not have expertise in and then the
mathematicians coming to help out is
that kind of what happens there that's
kind of what happens it's actually an
interesting back and forth so of course
discovering Einstein's equations and the
solutions to it that describe the shape
of space-time around things like black
holes was revolutionary
um and of course new math needed to be
introduced to be able to
calculate these uh objects but
additionally just the fact that we now
know our universe hosts these objects
black holes neutron stars these strong
gravity environments uh leads to just
mathematical questions about whether
space-time itself is uh stable for
instance and so the mathematicians have
a back and forth interplay with the
physicists when it comes to asking
questions about gravity
um the Delight that that completely
spooked me when you said I said stable
space time might not be stable okay yeah
what happened did we break up with
another Universe in the multi-universe
the question of stability is is it
shouldn't be as scary as it sounds
certainly we think it should be stable
we it hasn't broken yet we're still all
here to ask these questions so we don't
think it's broken yet it's more so just
though mathematically understanding if
something is stable is a little bit
different from you know just by fiance
We Exist therefore it is so we and Chuck
it has nothing to do with emotional
stability okay that's that's where I'm
gonna go immediately
yeah so Delilah is there to tell us what
space time is and space-time geometry
just so we're all on the same page
absolutely so let me back up a little
bit and just talk about you know our own
intuition we live in a world where we're
able to move around and we kind of can
get this feel that there are three
dimensions in which we can move we can
move back and forth we can move left to
right or we can move up and down right
and so that feels like three dimensions
and you know for a long time we used uh
classical mechanics uh and Newtonian
gravity to describe what was going on in
that situation but when Einstein came
along with special relativity he told us
that time the way we perceive sequences
of events is also related to the
dimensions that feel like spatial
Dimensions to us so what we actually
have to do is think of space and time as
being one object and to move from
thinking about them as just one object
this object also has a shape and this is
when
Einstein added general relativity to
tell us about what that shape is there's
this relationship between the shape of
quote-unquote space-time this fabric
that we all live in which has to do with
the way we're allowed to move physically
through space as well as the way we
perceive time flowing in space this one
object is shaped by the stuff that's in
it so gravity is given to us by general
relativity from Einstein tells us energy
in matter tell space time how to be
shaped and the way that space time is
shaped tells matter how to move
throughout space-time what paths it
should take
wow all right so when you have your when
you have your your your high gravity
objects that tests your ideas and the
mathematics uh at their limits in a way
right because I guess all everything
that you described Is Happening Here and
Now around us but it's not manifesting
in any important way that we would
change our lives based on it right
that's right it's true that
for the most part we can use you know
classical mechanics and Newtonian
gravity for the way things are and we
don't have to Delilah it was good enough
it was good enough for my grandparents
okay it's honestly good enough for all
of us when we drive our cars when we
throw baseballs you know we don't have
to think about oh my goodness how is the
baseball warping space and time as I
throw it to my friends yeah my
generation we were that was good enough
for us I think most of us actually uh
live our physical intuitive lives
without having to appeal to it
um but you know even even uh in the time
of Einstein it became relevant it was
you know first tested general relativity
and the corrections it makes to
newtonian's gravity was first tested
using
um solar eclipses
um so uh even the way our Sky appears
you know is affected by by general
relativity
um even though we don't need it for the
way we intuitively move about our day
for both for the most part as I
understand it the entire Apollo program
used just Newtonian gravity so like it
was good enough for us to get to the
moon absolutely a few young
whippersnappers that are trying to do
something extra with it so so we have
questions that we solicited from our uh
patreon fan base and if you want to ask
questions too out there uh you can join
our patreon and there's a pretty
affordable lowest level where you get to
ask these questions and so Chuck you you
compiled them yeah these are all
specifically for Delilah
um Christine dolman says uh hello Dr
Tyson Dr Gates and search up now that's
Lord Chuck Christie
um I'm a teacher and a young scientist I
love facilitating facilitating the study
of geometry how are two and
three-dimensional shapes represented
Across the Universe spheres are easy but
what about the rest aha yes well the
fear the spears happen even even here
naturally underwater and for some reason
everything becomes a sphere so
what's going on there and what about the
rest
well I guess you know when thinking
about the shapes of various things
um often the question is you know what
is energetically easy spheres are easy
and it's because you know you can
make things smooth and try to you know
fit a minimal surface area around a
maximal amount of volume
for if you think about a fun thing is if
you think about water in space if you
have a drop of water it's roughly
spherical when it floats in Space
unencumbered by the force of gravity of
course if you touch it a little bit at
all it'll vibrate and wiggle but it
wants to be spherical because of the
surface tension
um trying to find an easy way to relax
but
um I will say what about the rest about
shapes throughout space if we're
thinking about objects one thing that I
think is profound is that in physics we
kind of think that things are generic we
think that the laws of physics here are
the laws of physics everywhere and we
try to come up with with theories that
describe the whole of what happens
anywhere in the universe and of course
this is what we want I
do hope the way I throw a ball uh is the
same way I would throw it on one side of
the Earth or another side of the Earth
or if I went to the moon as long as I
calculate for the change in the mass of
the the planet I'm standing on so the
shapes should all be described in the
same way uh depending regardless of
where we are in the universe
okay oh it's okay it's very clean that's
very good all right okay on Earth as it
is in the heavens
that was good all right all right give
me another one great question Christine
Tolman thanks this is Trevor C Mills
Trevor is coming to us from Augusta
Georgia uh Georgia he says greetings
this is Dr Tyson Dr Gates and Chuck I
know that currently it is not believed
that wormholes sizable ones at least
have the ability to be stable is this
due to the geometry of space-time itself
if so what about the geometry of
space-time prevents stable wormholes and
if not then does then what does prevent
stable wormholes
so this is you know when people ask that
I try to ask them how old they are
because if they're like 12 or 13 then
you got to check the basement see if
they're making something down there
since I get the Nemesis of superheroes
sounds like an innocent question you
know on the surface yeah so Delilah an
addendum here is and if I were to create
a wormhole would I be able to get one
billion dollars okay
I'm sure if we created a wormhole you
know someone would try to try to use it
to make money yeah for nefarious ways so
Delight we mentioned instabilities
earlier and here we're talking about the
stability of a wormhole so what's up
with that so I will say as a caveat my
expertise is not
um math so this is a question the
mathematical side as a mathematician of
general relativity or space-time
geometries but from my understanding
this goes to the question of the way
things changed when you add additional
matter
um often when we solve for the shape of
space-time and Einstein's equations
analytically
um we only do it in specific
circumstances where everything all the
matter is only say in the black hole or
the neutron star very calm compact but
of course you know if you want to jump
through a wormhole you're yourself
matter and if you are a matter you cause
according to Einstein's equations the
shape of space-time to change slightly
so when mathematicians try to understand
the stability of of space-time of
certain space-time objects like black
holes or wormholes what they really have
to do is add a little bit to the
mathematical description of the shape to
account for adding say a person trying
to Jump Through the Wormhole and then
you have to calculate whether or not the
the equations break down or it can
settle back down into their original
form once the person has Moved Through
the Wormhole and that's the hard thing
to do I don't know what the generic
rules are about what make this up but
typically stability is not an easy thing
to prove it's still an open question
whether spinning black holes
are stable I'd heard we need some kind
of negative gravity to do this is that
correct
to pry it open I had some vague memory
of this right this is not something I'm
familiar about whether negative gravity
is necessary wow okay sorry how does
negative gravity work you know it's like
I tried to be on Earth but it kept
throwing me off
well in a way we could consider a dark
energy negative gravity you know oh yeah
well that's what I'm saying you just
want to come together together yeah
exactly but the universe because of dark
energy wants to spread apart
oh wow negative gravity is dark energy
that's pretty cool man yeah so negative
innocent energy density yeah yeah yeah
cool okay all right all right so so what
you're saying is the
um it's still not a completely solved
problem which is interesting which keeps
open the doorway for science fiction
writers and I don't have a problem with
that you know as long as we we give them
a little bit of latitude let them run
with it it also keeps the door open for
mathematicians who want to study the
area
all right what do you have next all
right here we go this is uh let's see
here Let's uh let's move away from home
and go to Quentin in Switzerland
and Quentin says if the universe
has a closed spherical spherical shape
could one of the galaxies in the sky
that we look at be the Milky Way in its
past State oh wow so can we look out and
then see around
I see I need to get a shape up in the
back of my head
actually we got to take a quick break
but when we come back we're gonna find
out the answer to whether if the
universe is spherical does looking out
in One Direction end up coming right
back
so that you can see the back of your own
head or at least the back of the Milky
Way's head when start talk continues
with our guest Delilah Gates
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries talk
about space-time geometry and
gravitation with freshly minted PhD
Delilah Gates who is now at Princeton
University in their gravity Initiative
Program that's just so audacious it's
like no there's still some gravity we
don't understand and we got to figure
this out and let's get some smart people
all in the same place at the same time
see what I did there yeah
see see how clever I was about that
that's right based on jokes I know
so so uh this is a question from
Switzerland just read it back real quick
sure thing sure sure thing this is
Quentin from Switzerland he said if the
universe had a closed spherical shape
could one of the galaxies in the sky be
the Milky Way in its past state
interesting so this is a great question
and in principle the answer is if the
universe had a closed uh spherical
geometry then indeed we could see the
our own Milky Way in the sky but there
is one problem however
or one other element you need to
consider even if the universe is
spherical you also have to consider its
size there would have had to be enough
time since the Milky Way started for the
light from it to reach us so even if the
universe was spherical but the universe
was too big the light from
the from our universe that went around
ball the back around and then to come
back at us wouldn't have had enough time
so in principle the answer is yes but
you also need to consider how large the
universe is wow to understand whether
one would be our our own Galaxy that
we're seeing in our Sky then what's the
answer for this universe we then we
should know that right well we're big
enough are we small enough for that yeah
we don't we we don't see any evidence
that
um that the observable universe uh in
the observable universe in in all the
light we can see
um from starting close to the big bang
with things like the cosmic microwave
background
um we don't see any evidence that our
universe is uh closed and spherical
oh wow another thing is we also if you
talk about whether the universe is close
it doesn't have to be a sphere there are
other close geometries uh like Tori
um and I don't I don't I don't know what
a Tori is a Taurus
dude
now I know it's not an astrology side
it's a it's a daughter
that's it okay that's the first time I
ever heard Tori okay you know a tourists
all right so what you're saying is we
we're in an open Universe not a closed
Universe
we're deaf there's definitely no
evidence we're in a closed one and
there's also no evidence that we are on
a geometry that is curved like a sphere
um okay for instance if you even if you
didn't knew the universe was big enough
that you couldn't have seen the light
from yourself wrap back around you might
um say that doesn't matter I can just
look at the overall curvature of the
space time and we don't have any
evidence that the curvature of the space
time isn't flat we all our evidence is
has an error constraining around it
constraining it around being flat
geometry so in other words the
uncertainties Even in our understanding
of the flat universe do not include the
possibility of us being closed well yes
that's correct
oh right intuitive
about it if the universe not if we know
the universe is expanded and you look
into space it doesn't have to be
expanding in all directions all at once
which the only thing that we know that
goes in all directions all at once is
you know like a spear and an ellipse or
something like that so intuitively your
mind goes to oh it's got to be shaped
like that
um I think intuitively from geometry
that we understand might suspect that
but actually I think that's a little bit
of of of where you have to actually use
your math to tell you uh that you should
be careful of your own intuition because
at large scales we don't necessarily
intuitively have to live by the rules of
say Newtonian gravity
um uh that's because consider you know
just a plane if you were a
two-dimensional being and you lived on a
plane that plane could go on forever
without having to be wrapped around such
that it didn't have a um just that it
closed it on itself so it could just be
you're on an infinite plane
um and then of course you can extend
that into 3ds to have an infinite volume
right
um so intuitively this is a case where
we got to check our math and tell
ourselves we don't necessarily have to
be in a closed Universe I love it
stop using your damn intuition okay
believe me that we gave up on that a
long time ago
I I opened one of my books with with the
statement the universe is under no
obligation to make sense to you yeah
it's very cool just put that out I love
that we like it we like that okay what
more do you have Chuck from our patreon
members people ongoing with uh patreon
member Dylan who says greetings Dr Tyson
Dr Gates Chucky baby undergrad and
astrophysics at NAU in Flagstaff that's
where you'll find me General relatively
allows for three possible shapes of the
universe you clearly in positive and
negative curvatures curious on which
shape you most lean towards so we just
got finished talking about uh you know
how we got to check the math not to be
uh relying on our intuition but now we
have a question directly to you doc well
where do you come down on the whole
shape issue
um well I I tend to I tend to be could
conservative and trust my colleagues and
so there's amazing experimentalists out
there who have so far shown us that we
shouldn't expect that the Universe
overall has a curvature so I definitely
lean towards uh it being being flat I
will say you know when people
ask this question I want to caveat this
is on large scales of course Gravity the
gravity tells us that there is curvature
where there's matter so certainly around
black holes the space time is very
curved but it's like on large scales if
you average it we think it's it's
relatively flat yeah and to your last
point we have pictures of that that's of
course we think that because we we've
actually seen it not the black hole
itself but how light interplays around
the black hole so we know that what's
just said you know that it's curved
absolutely speaking of black holes uh we
had a question earlier about the this
idea of seeing the back of our our Milky
Way if we were in a closed spherical
small enough uh geometry for our
universe even if we're not a place where
you can potentially see the back side of
uh your own head is actually around a
black hole black holes have a region
around them called the photon sphere and
this is a region where light can wrap
around many times around the black hole
coming pretty close to its original
position before either spiraling out
very far away from the black hole or
falling into the black hole so if you
want to see the back of your head go
near a Blackboard so the light is
basically in orbit around the black hole
that's right is that a fair way to say
that yeah so you look straight ahead
and you will see light that headed
backwards and came around to the front
of your face and that would be your your
nap the nappy back your head that's
right that's what we're talking about
right right wow that is so cool that
would make for a weird picnic you know
do you know who you're looking at the
front and the back of them at the same
time and then you walk towards them but
you don't know which one you look I mean
yeah that would that's that's something
somebody needs to do in a movie yeah oh
absolutely imagine it'd be very
disorienting yeah worse yeah worst movie
theater ever
down in front
oh wow oh that's a bad fascinating
fascinating little uh the photon sphere
very cool yes Photon sphere love it keep
it going chuck all right here we go this
is Tegan Messier and Tegan says hello Dr
Gates this is Tegan from British
Columbia here uh what shape do you think
our universe is we already said that
um I heard an idea that it could be
shaped like the DNA molecule since the
DNA is the best way to store information
that we are aware of any thoughts on
this so now the reason why I read this
is because there are a lot of people who
actually make connections between our
own physiology our brain our
neurosynaptical systems and the universe
itself uh do you see any connection
there
I will say there's uh the shape of DNA
is a kind of funny and yd shape so
there's no reason to accept expect that
to be the shape of our universe but I do
think there are a lot of uh beautiful
analogies between
um Humanity our own DNA
um the structures shapes of things here
on Earth and the shape of things that we
see in the sky like
um the shape of where matter is
following the galaxies and dark matter
if we run simulations to see where the
stuff is clumped it has
um interesting patterns that feel a lot
of like kinds of natural quote-unquote
patterns we'd see here on Earth and I
think uh one of my favorite
analogies between humanity and the
universe is the fact that we are all
made up of cells and yet we are
conscious and so we're tiny cells that
somehow have become conscious and can
ask questions about ourselves in the
same way
um we are made up of the same stuff as
the rest of the Universe
um and so humanity and any other
sentient life out there that's asking
such questions is really you know made
up of these tiny things and then able to
query itself about itself where the
universe asking itself about itself and
I think that's pretty pretty darn cool
damn damn
all right good night ladies and
gentlemen that's our show
you can't follow that with anything
right what do you do
so I think it was in the in the Carl
Sagan era there was the phrase uh uh
humans are a way for the universe to
know itself
and I I that sounds all poetic but it's
kind of egocentric because it implies
that we are the ultimate source of how
you the universe can know itself when it
could have made some way smarter aliens
around in the other sector okay well I
did say us in any other sentient beings
out there yeah I do think it's humorous
okay good
completely of course yes yes well look
at that keep it going look at that all
you uh all you um extraterrestrial
enthusiasts out there we're not alone
you just heard it here okay uh this is
Brian Lacy hello it's Brian from
Baltimore
I've heard of toroidal shapes like the
donut and that our universe may even be
that how does it work in wait a minute
here's the questions because we just
touched on that so just to let you know
I'm not crazy
how does this work in Upper dimensions
so that's that's the difference from
what we just touched upon about the Tori
so you know
how do things change once we get to
other dimensions
so if we add Dimensions
um actually you know depending on what
we're describing things don't change too
much
um we can think about we know how to
measure
um the curvature of shapes actually it
turns out intrinsically which means we
don't have to embed them in higher
Dimensions to know how to measure their
curvature so you know you might think I
can measure the shape of a circle
because I can hold an object that's a
circle but if I lived on the circle I
wouldn't be able to describe its shape
unless it was small enough for me to
walk all the way around and come back to
the same point but in Geometry this
isn't quite true there are intrinsic
ways in principle to measure curvature
so we can get at the curvature
um even if we live in the space time and
so the same measures we would use to say
is space-time curved in our three plus
one that means three space plus one time
space-time that we live in we could play
the same mathematical games and use
similar experiments that we've developed
to measure the the shape of space-time
in higher Dimensions it turns out what
does what is a higher dimensional Taurus
like what is that well I it's a
it's a shape I can't draw on a piece of
paper because we only have so many
dimensions
um but it's more or less in a way the
same similar to what we have now you
could think of having describing a
Taurus at least
topologically you can describe a Taurus
as uh as a as taking a closed object
like a sphere and then puncturing it and
you can count you can describe Tori by
how many punctures they have there's the
donut which has one puncture you know
you've seen inner tubes where they're
where you when you go down a um like a
water slide where two people can sit on
it that's a Taurus with two holes or we
call the holes genus and so you can do
the same game in higher dimensions and
you can say starting with a closed shape
and I'd puncture holes into it and I can
describe it by how many holes it has
whoa that is really dope that is cool
two-seater water slide I'll be thinking
of this conversation absolutely for sure
right all right that's one of the fun
things about being a physicist is you
can you can think about analogies to
stop your learning in physics and math
geometry Etc uh when you come across
everyday objects and it makes them in my
mind feel even more exciting to to think
about
cool all right all right all right Chuck
keep it going this is high do and high
do says hello Dr Gates Dr Tyson Lord
nice I've always wondered if the golden
ratio ever applied to anything
astrophysical in nature if not why we
hear it used often with terrestrial
architecture art music
Etc do you ever find these examples in
astrophysics
wow um so
um maybe uh Neil can tell us more but uh
to my understanding I'm not sure that
the golden ratio uh tends to pop up in
any um astronomical observables or
measures to my knowledge
um I haven't I haven't seen it either
um so yeah
I think one thing that does you know in
a sense pop up more often is pi
um but that's because pie is related to
spheres so a lot of equations like um
um Einstein's equation for instance has
pi in it
it is where Pi shows up in the in in the
most unlikely places that you never
think yes there it is like how'd you get
it who let you win who ordered that
right right some of us order pizza pies
and some of us sort of uh the number pot
there you go
all right let's move on
um this is a Zuber sing
um he says hello Dr Gates Dr Tyson and
Chuck here's my question how does the
armor how does the geometry of
space-time change in the presence of
massive objects like a black hole and
how does this affect motion of objects
in the vicinity of those massive objects
so I mean if you want to talk truth
truly massive would have to be you know
black holes at the center of our
galaxies
absolutely so
um you know we all know that our planets
for instance in our solar system orbit
the Sun and so this is this effect where
we can get matter to travel around an
object many times is the name namely one
of the biggest features of having
massive Mass uh really concentrated and
so when we concentrate Mass even more
into a smaller area and we get even
heavier objects these effects get more
and more pronounced namely for black
holes the defining feature of them is
that you have so much gravity that not
only is it planets or other massive
objects that can get on paths that um
are closed you also can get the same
thing happening to light and you can
even get it such that you have the Event
Horizon
um gravity so strong that even light
can't escape from the black hole if it
gets too close so it's just a bigger and
more pronounced effect of what you
probably know from your astronomy
classes or science class when you learn
about planets being able to be on orbits
and if like I mentioned the photon
sphere earlier you can get light bending
around black holes multiple time and of
course you have the defining feature of
them the Event Horizon
um the surface around the black hole the
the area from which if light gets caught
uh if light goes to that that area that
it won't be able to escape the gravity
and leave the planet leave the black
hole excuse me that's pretty cool yeah
now you just said you know what this
proton sphere again and what just popped
into my head as a question is
how are you recognizing the same light
as opposed to the new light that's
coming in from behind the black hole so
how are you identifying these are the
same photons that we just registered
whenever
great question so
if you are thinking about the problem
from a mathematical standpoint you can
do the following you can say I have I
can shoot light from different positions
around the black hole and watch uh and
calculate all the paths that it can take
and so it's when you do that if you say
I have a source here and an observer
here I shoot off light and I watch the
different paths that connect my Observer
and my source or my source and my
Observer then you can just look at the
different paths to see how many times it
winds in actuality in the real world we
don't have experiments that are so
um powerful yet that we can necessarily
easily detect
the light from an object being the light
that wound many times but in principle
one could look at say a black hole that
has stuff spirally around it and they
could look for uh statistically
correlations in the image to know that
they saw
um light from that object that wound
different amounts of time okay all right
excellent all right Chuck we gotta take
a break oh okay we'll come back we'll
come back for our third and final
segment of cosmic queries
space-time continuous Edition when the
Star Talk returns
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
we're talking about the space-time
Continuum with Dr Delilah Gates of
Princeton University uh do I understand
correctly that you you make an
appearance in the Netflix series what's
it called here a trip to Infinity is
that correct that's correct uh
um there's a
um a um Netflix special called a trip to
Infinity which I appear in and it has
experts
mathematicians physicists philosophers
and
um
we take the chance to discuss what it's
like to try to Grapple with the concept
of infinity what it means to
mathematicians and physicists and
philosophers and try to give people a
way to understand it I don't really care
for self-promotion but I think it's
wonderfully done has beautiful
animations and can give anyone the sense
of awe that I feel and that I think many
physicists and and scientists feel who
think about these kinds of problems when
we when we do our work I love it I have
a bookmarked and I haven't watched it
but now I'm gonna watch it all right
Chuck we have a last segment last
segment we'll make it quick I mean I'll
keep things moving but first let me just
give the PS to uh uh Zuber Singh who I
promised that I would but uh and he says
my educational background is in the
humanities but because of Neil and
Cosmos I am now a huge fan of
astrophysics I love what you're doing I
just wanted to say that okay okay let's
do this this is Colby lapressi who says
this hey it's Colby from South Carolina
here hi Neil how Chuck how Dr Kings why
do we always see galaxies appear closer
and closer together when we look deeper
and deeper in space does this have any
indication of the shape of the cosmos
um
um I get that we're looking back but
what's the deal okay there you go I
think uh the deal is twofold I think one
as we can see further and further away
um of course if you think about having a
forest and you can only see the trees a
certain distance and then you can see
tree you can add on distances it seems
more dense not that they weren't always
there but just because you have farther
depth in Your Vision so it seems more
crowded because you're seeing further
and further away black uh galaxies
stacked on top of each other so that's
one and then two but it's a line of
sights that's a line of sight thing
that's a line of sight thing and then I
think yeah it's not that they're
actually next to each other they're
they're just lined up in your line of
sight and they feel like they're
crowding exactly and I think the
photographer in photography that's
called depth of field and when you use a
longer lens to take a picture you can
squish things together with a telephoto
lens but go ahead absolutely so there's
the depth of feel but then also because
we are the way we view things we view
things um kind of you know from one
position if you view things you view
things in a code you have a conical view
outward so additionally at you can stack
more things kind of directly behind each
other so it looks denser but you also as
you look out you see
um a conical
um kind of field of view and so you have
based on just the shape of a cone right
you could fit less things here than you
could fit at the top of the cone so the
top of the cone the things that are
farther away you can also see more of
those so it's I think it's part of it is
depth as well as the fact that we view
things conically so it looks like we're
seeing more and more and then
um but it's not actually a statement
necessarily about
um Gallop something having fundamentally
changed those galaxies were there
they've been there for a long time it's
just we have new technology
wow and by the way galaxies do Collide
so it's not that that does happen but I
want to add something here and that is
in the past because if you look out in
space you're looking back in time the
universe was smaller than it is today
so
this angle of view that you send out to
the edge of the universe actually
encloses much more of the universe in
the early time that it does in the later
time simply because the universe was
smaller it's an interesting phenomenon
that we that we see so we have to adjust
measures of the distances between things
that we get from the angle that we see
so so that there would be distortions on
this cone that Delilah was talking about
yeah wow so the cone doesn't go straight
out the cone actually focuses back a bit
as you go out there and so cramming in
more of the universe into the field of
view it's a pretty cool effect actually
Adelaide who says uh I often see
Adelaide Australia yes sir
Australia okay and yeah we're getting
them from all over the world today man
right people are interested in this uh
this subject Woody says I often see
visualizations and descriptions of the
fabric of space-time where a 3D
structure stretches and bends but is it
possible for space time to be anything
like a fluid near or inside of an event
horizon
oh I like that wow
I'll start with the fact that we don't
know what happens inside of an event
horizon we can make mathematical
speculations but like uh we Neil said
the universe has uh is not obligated to
be understandable by us or be
um in accordance with what we've so far
calculated and since an event horizon by
definition is a region from which light
cannot Escape we can get no information
about what's behind it at least as far
as our understanding is today
um but if we even think about the space
time that we have outside of black holes
um we can't think of it in a way as
something that is in motion
um
because sources of that's things like
black holes galaxies planets all these
things are moving so the shape of space
time around them is also always
dynamically changing and adjusting as
the matter moves on top of it
um and in fact enabled to in order to
understand
um the gravitational wave detections
that we have from ligo
and the other
um experiments kagra and such we have to
dynamically calculate the way space-time
changes stretches uh and contracts
because of the two massive objects
spinning in on each other to emit
gravitational waves so in fact yes the
universe is like a fabric or a
geometrical shape but it's not rigid
okay here we go this is Bruce Ryan Bruce
Ryan is from Alexandria Virginia he says
I once heard Neil say that there is no
center of the universe hey what's up
with that if the universe started from a
single point there has to be a center at
some moment okay uh no Delilah dig us
out of that one so if
um this is the
um again where our intuition is is
fooling us if we think about uh
what we're used to
um but in fact
um we know for instance the for instance
that the universe is probably not uh
shaped like a sphere but for a moment
suppose it was if it was shaped like a
sphere and Europe items a person who
lives on a sphere who's to say what
point is more special than any other
point on that sphere and so when we say
that the universe is expanding it's not
talking about
um it's not talking about
spanning away from any one given point
that's the center it's the whole thing
expanding in size think of drawing a
point on the surface of a balloon and
then blowing up the balloon all points
on the surface of the sphere get farther
and farther away from each other but
none of them is more special than the
others and this is what we mean when we
say there's no Center to the universe
despite the fact that it's expanding
I like to think of it that there is a
center but you don't you can only find
it if you go back in time
so it's a place in time not in space yes
excellent a place into yeah see my
answer is the universe is in the words
of Little Richard me
okay
[Laughter]
Little Richard the only one who have
ever said me
he's the only one that ever said it like
that like that that's right I like that
yes I love okay sorry just want to give
it love that guy he's dead but who cares
all right all right quick last one give
it to me can we get it all right let me
let me last one here that is quick a
delight you got to go on sound bite
sound bite mode all right Delilah okay
all right let's go all right this is
Jesse Desmond okay I picked the wrong
one because I don't even know what this
is but I'm gonna do it anyway
could the Mandela affect be the result
of a parallel universe colliding with
ours imagine two bubbles colliding but
instead of bursting uh they form a
double bubble
I hesitate to say the answer I hesitate
to say yes to that
um I just because I don't understand how
mathematically we would set up the
situation to describe this and
Mathematics is King and theoretical
physics you have to write down your
theory and then test it so okay if we
don't have that I hesitate to put any
weight behind it sorry so
it remind us of the Mandela effect
described here is that the Mandela
effect is this effect where we
misremember like like large swaths of
people will remember something falsely
like
um Luke I am your father in Star Wars I
think he just says I am your father I
think yeah he never says or bear
steinbears versus Berenstain Bears so
it's this thing where it seems like as a
whole lots of people seem to misremember
something uh which feels uncanny
right right
there's another one like uh it was uh uh
played against Sam there was no again he
just says play it Sam I'm pretty sure oh
cool wow yeah I think of course or the
up the inverse of that but what people
misremember that collectively are
certain about what their memory is and
it's just all wrong so what is it we're
misremembering about Mandela that he's
not Dr Martin Luther King
stop
I think it might be when he died is what
people misremember all right well there
you have it he's got he's got the name
so the day we do discover parallel
universes intersecting in ways that are
interesting Mandela is remembered for
this this is cool I like that yes and
and not Luke
not Starbucks not the Luke effect let
there be some social justice gained by
the Collision of two parallel universes
well Delilah it's been it's been
delightful to have you on and
congratulations on your recently minted
PhD uh good luck sometimes you need a
little bit of that uh going forward uh
in this universe and if you make any new
discoveries or you hear about anything
very cool give us a holler we'll put you
right back on yeah because it's clear
first
really good this has been Star Talk
Cosmic queries Edition with Dr Delilah
Gates
a newly minted PhD at Princeton
University right down the block from us
in New York Chuck always good to have
you man always a pleasure Neil deGrasse
Tyson here as always be to you you keep
looking up
foreign
[Music]